no no wait till after the Pats game this  season has been pretty dark thank God  for the quarter season carnival football  yeah tell me anyway  oh hey Cincinnati I hit the board  intercepted and it's coming back ah you  did it Kirk life is a carnival you see  you got one dolly go come on sorry it's  not safe for you scramble I understand  this rides not for everyone I can handle  it Ross  I'm surprisingly keeping up I could  scramble forever let me fly hey man you  do whatever you want I don't care this  is normally when I stop watch this no I  I'm footballs Tom Brady please buy my  special pliability room bus why would I  do that  can't you get high I'm Julian Edelman  and I know Tom Brady please subscribe to  this channel